my ultimate goal is just to have my name
up there with my dad's name when they're
picking some of the best drivers in the
industry to work on a big car show you
know I don't want to be the best woman
driver the best black woman driver I
want to be the best driver and one of
the best drivers don't get too cocky
because denying of the other work
[Music]
my name is Brianna Lynch I'm 21 years
old and I've been a stunt driver for
four and a half years my name is Julie
Oh J Lynch I'm her dad
and I've been in the business for 27
years all the dangerous stuff that the
cars are doing in the movies all the
exciting stuff we do that and not the
actors so a couple of the films that I
worked on our Black Panther Proud Mary
Fast and Furious 8 Beyonce's music video
formation and creepy and that's me and
my dad right there I got started in the
business to a New Jack city I've done
all the Fast & Furious series since
number four and Jumanji and I'm one of
the guys up there on the bike yep that's
me right there so cool cuz I am the
coolest farmer when my dad and I are
working together we actually like to
help each other set the cars up so when
I have to do something like sliding
around the corner my dad is right there
with me trying to make sure that
everything is set up so I think that's
what makes my dad and I really unique I
[Applause]
got into stunt driving because of my dad
they taught me how to ride when I was
three years old he's been teaching me in
my entire life he's so good at what he
does and so respected in this industry
so since I started son driving he has
been my motivator and my coach my
teacher he's everything but my
accountant pretty much
one of the things that I had learned by
riding with her all the time was that
she was able to handle the pressure 3 2
1 action as much as people don't believe
that you're inside a car when they
explode people are in those vehicles so
it's a lot to let your kid go and be in
danger I guess part of being a parent
and part of being in the stunt business
we do as much as we can to keep her as
safe as possible and then after that you
wish for the best
I love that I get to share stunt driving
with my dad I think that's a really cool
bond that the two of us have my dad and
I always been very close he's very
supportive of me chasing down this dream
that I have and if you want to be good
at something you have to put the time in
it's important for you to enjoy your
life and to actually love what you're
doing that's the biggest picture at the
end of the day
you
[Music]